yesterday one day after the shocking fbi
raid on mar-a-lago joe biden's attorney
general merrick garland has come forward
to take responsibility for the
unprecedented attack on the former
president who just so happens to be
biden's chief political rival in 2024
just now the justice department has
filed a motion in the southern district
of florida to unseal a search warrant
and property receipt
relating to a court approved search that
the fbi conducted earlier this week
that search was of premises located in
florida belonging to the former
president faithful adherence to the rule
of law is the bedrock principle of the
justice department
and of our democracy
upholding the rule of law means applying
the law evenly
without fear or favor
under my watch that is precisely what
the justice department is doing federal
law
long-standing department rules and our
ethical obligations
prevent me from providing further
details as to the basis of the search at
this time
there are however certain points i want
you to know
first
i personally approved the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter let
me address recent unfounded attacks on
the professionalism of the fbi
and justice department agents and
prosecutors
i will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
merrick garland will not stand by
silently while the integrity of the fbi
and doj leadership is unfairly attacked
how about when it's fairly attacked
unfair
unfounded just to be clear we're talking
about the same doj and fbi that
conspired with the democrats and
fabricated evidence that trump had
colluded with the russians in order to
spy on the trump campaign then later
launched a years-long 32 million dollar
special counsel investigation also based
on nothing to undermine the trump
administration after trump entered
office and then two days ago sent
jack-booted thugs to raid the home of
the current president's predecessor and
chief rival ostensibly to enforce a law
that many other presidents and even
presidential candidates such as hillary
clinton more egregiously have violated
without consequence
that's the doj that's the fbi that we're
not allowed to criticize according to
merrick garland merrick garland the
jilted former federal judge who is now
exacting revenge on his political
enemies because cocaine mitch mcconnell
and the republicans denied him his dream
job on the supreme court
how dare you attack my integrity i'm not
going to attack merrick garland's
integrity or the integrity of the doj
and fbi leadership because that would
imply that they have any integrity to
attack and they do not
they have four years now revealed
themselves to be political hacks whose
job it is to destroy republicans and to
let democrat criminals such as hillary
clinton such as hunter biden we could be
here all day if we kept listing the
names to let them off the hook for
committing more serious crimes than any
of the crimes that they even accuse the
republicans of
in the case of trump
they have revealed themselves as the boy
who cried wolf
accusing trump of all sorts of nonsense
from the fake dossier about the alleged
hooker urine tape you remember that one
that was a doozy to all the other vague
claims of bribes and blackmail and
collusion without ever once producing
the goods no evidence whatsoever just
all sorts of insinuation
these people merit garland in particular
should be ashamed of what they have done
to the rule of law in the united states
and as far as i'm concerned unless the
fbi found severed heads in a freezer at
mar-a-lago
nothing could justify this raid which
unlike donald trump poses a genuine
threat to our democracy i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from inaccessible
cardinal who says my new year's
resolution was to drop 10 pounds i
finally hit my target this month
granted i gained 78 pounds over the
first six months of the year that's true
kind of like inflation don't you think
inflation goes up
goes up to 40 your record highs and then
it comes down to three cents
per gallon of gas or whatever and you
say oh look look at how great this is
zero inflation negative inflation which
is also bad too by the way biden just
doesn't realize that absolutely right
great point congratulations on only
gaining 68 pounds this year good job
when
we want to speak the truth we can't
necessarily do so on social media we
can't necessarily do so in the
mainstream press we've got to just
talk personally to people that we trust
and have respect for when i want to talk
to my friends you know i always got to
turn to pure talk usa right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code knowles
podcast byte inflation has left every
business trying to nickel and dime you
how much can they squeeze you to offset
their increasing costs who knows who
knows they're going to just keep going
up and up and up that's why i love pure
talk pure talk drew the line and said no
stop screwing over the american public
when you sign up with pure talk this
month you're going to get their best
offer yet
one
month
free when you sign up with puretalk you
will already save probably two-thirds on
whatever you're paying right now for
your cell phone plan and you're gonna
get that talk that text that data on
america's most reliable 5g network
you're not going to sacrifice any
service whatsoever you're going to pay
just 30 bucks a month and now on top of
that you're going to get one month free
when you make the switch today go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast for this special offer when you
choose puretalk you're choosing to
support american jobs not a company that
sends those jobs overseas you're
choosing to support a veteran-owned
american-based company not to mention a
big sponsor of everything we do here at
the daily wire go to puretalk.com select
a plan maybe add a new iphone a new
android then enter promo code knowles
podcast to get one month free
the walls are closing in on trump
they've got him now
oh they've got him now the the fbi and
the doj they've got him
i mean they've been saying that for
seven years straight now
and every time they insinuate or even
explicitly claim that he's committed
some terrible offense it never actually
happened and it was always fake
going back to that fake dossier that
they cooked up with the democrats in the
hillary campaign
and then what else did we have we had
the the urine tape we had do you
remember the the ukraine phone call the
walls are closing in
we've got him now trump called
president zielenski in ukraine who for a
while was portrayed as corrupt but now
they've switched the narrative on that
so now he's winston churchill but still
he called him bad
very that was bad it's it's mueller time
you remember that stupid t-shirt
remember the mueller investigation
that's going to take trump down the
walls are closing in whereas oh nope
nothing nothing we have nothing on him
okay
but now that what are they saying
they've got now it's it's so desperate
it's so pathetic
initially they were going after trump
for his alleged business corruption
that's why he was just deposed in new
york by the attorney general of new york
leticia james it's his business
corruption that the walls are closing in
and then they said that he violated the
presidential records act
which is this
part of federal law that says that the
national archives gets to own it
basically every piece of paper in the
white house and trump took some papers
which means he violated the law we're
going to send him to jail now except
pretty much every president
technically violates the presidential
records act
if barack obama technically violated it
he's kept a ton of document millions and
millions of documents that he was
supposed to turn over to the national
archives that he's just keeping in
chicago at his presidential library and
he said that he was going to digitize
them by the way the excuse that obama
used to keep all of his documents was
well i'm going to digitize them and make
them public five years later not a
single document's been digitized but
okay that's barack obama
this goes back to lbj violated the
presidential records act richard nixon
held richard nixon his
his library held on to tapes until 2010
or 2013 okay this has never been
enforced it's a it's preposterous
the doj was apparently working with
trump to get some of these documents
back they were aware of it they saw the
boxes of documents they even told him to
put a padlock on the room
reportedly
and then the raid the raid up because
the walls are closed so what are they
saying the raid is about now when there
was such huge blowback against it
they're saying it's that donald trump
had nuclear secrets
he stole the nuclear codes or something
that's what the washington post had fbi
searched trump's home to look for
nuclear documents and other items
sources say
okay so what could that possibly mean
some people are saying it means the
nuclear codes first of all
if my icloud account it makes me change
my password every six months i should
hope that the nuclear codes change every
once in a while i hope so i i have to
change my password when i log into
twitter regularly i should hope that uh
the the codes that could lead to a
nuclear apocalypse on earth i hope you
can you have to refresh those you know
add a few special characters and capital
letters one would hope but is it they
don't really say it's the codes though
what do they say it is
they say this is according to the
washington post
uh now citing the former chief of the
justice department's counterintelligence
section
if it is true that there are there is
all this classified nuclear information
it would suggest that the material
residing on lawfully at mar-a-lago may
have been classified at the highest
classification level if the fbi and the
doj believed there were top secret
materials still at mar-a-lago that would
lend itself to greater hair on fire
motivation to recover that material as
quickly as possible and this is why it
really doesn't hold up as far as i'm
concerned
so first of all this is all being
reported in the washington post the
washington post is pravda the washington
post is the propaganda bullhorn for the
deep state and the establishment it's
been true going back to the 1970s and
probably earlier
second
the sources cited in the washington post
article are anonymous
as as is frequently the case and when
when the washington post reports on
trump generally you got to take it with
a grain of salt because they hate his
guts when it's anonymous sources you
really got to take it with a grain of
salt but then they cite people on the
record responding to the anonymous
sources they say this was the highest
classification level right if hillary
clinton had this material at her home
that would be a huge problem
on her server because she has never been
the president she was a secretary of
state
and so
hillary clinton does not have the right
to declassify whatever she wants the
president does the president could have
the most super-duper top-secret material
in the world he could then take a
picture of it post it on twitter that
would be completely legal that is his
right
because he's the president and he
doesn't work for some hack at the doj
he's the president he can declassify
whatever he wants but then third of all
and this is i think to me
the the part that
really makes this whole thing fall apart
they say this is hair on fire stuff the
sense of urgency they had to get this
back if it's so urgent why'd they wait
what's it been 18 19 months of the bind
administration this is so urgent why
weren't they kicking down the doors at
mar-a-lago january 2021 if this is so
urgent why were they negotiating with
trump's lawyers this was so urgent why
did they see the material and say okay
no big deal put a padlock on it
just doesn't add up and when you when
you
put that in the context of the doj and
the fbi repeatedly consistently lying
about trump fabricating evidence in some
cases to get the fisa warrant for
crossfire hurricane to spy on his
campaign when you look at all of the
shenanigans some sometimes frequently
illegal that these these agencies have
undertaken to undermine trump you just
look at this and you say i don't buy it
kids i don't buy it this is an actual we
always hear about the assaults on our
democracy this is an actual assault on
our democracy this is the deep state and
the technocrats going after a man who at
least wants at least once has been the
duly elected president of the united
states
when you want to protect yourself
whether it be from freeze fire flood
raids whatever you gotta check out ring
right now head on over to ring.com
knowles summer is always super duper
busy we've all been away for a little
bit maybe you go on vacation maybe you
go visit family i was in the hospital
for a few days while we
well i won't say we gave birth to my new
son but my wife did and i was i was very
supportive there as well you know how i
can trust to protect my home
a lot of it's thanks to ring okay ring
not just the video doorbell where you
can see and speak to whoever is on the
other side of your door but ring also
has an award-winning alarm they've got
an award-winning home security system
with available professional monitoring
and if you want to be like me you can go
pro get ring alarm pro you protect not
just your physical home the windows and
the doors and all that stuff from the
freeze and the fire and the flood and
the bad guys but also your digital home
okay combines a security system with a
fast euro wi-fi six router for home
security and network security in one
device i love these guys absolutely
fabulous stuff plus they've been with us
pretty much since the beginning of the
show this busy summer to protect your
home go pro be a pro just like me ring
alarm pro learn more at ring.com knowles
that's ring.com
knowles
speaking of
the fake news
and the squandering of credibility by
our public
institutions i don't know whether to
laugh or to scream at this
headline that was posted on npr
yesterday npr
liberal outlet
taxpayer subsidized liberal outlet
on new kovid 19 guidance from the cdc
here's the guidance i didn't even
believe this was real when i saw this
infographic floating around the internet
i said this has to be a meme or a joke i
tracked down the source no it comes from
npr
npr getting it from the cdc
new covid19 guidance
from the cdc focuses on individual
decisions bullet point one
those exposed to the virus are no longer
required to quarantine
i'm gonna skip number two for a second
you'll see why number three students can
stay in class after being exposed to the
virus okay number four
it's no longer recommended to screen
those without symptoms okay and then
number two
unvaccinated people now have the same
guidance
as vaccinated people
unfortunately people um
[Laughter]
it's been two
and a half
years
people
lost their jobs
because they refused to take that stupid
fouchy ouchie that the libs
including walensky and fouchy and biden
all lied about lied about the efficacy
lied about the safety lied about the
whole thing and they said you have to
get it and if you won't take this
experimental drug you're going to lose
your job you're not going to get to see
your dying grandmother in the hospital
you can't go overseas you can't travel
you can't go to school you can't do
never mind
never mind now it's all the same
guidance for everybody oops
oops
i'm going to recover my composure
i'm going to just
patiently resign myself to the fact that
i
told you so i didn't need to tell you
you understood this from the beginning
but so many people from the beginning
said no fouchy's totally right the
vaccine is so wonderful everyone has to
take it beep boop beep boop follow the
science no no no there's no incompetence
here there are no ulterior motives there
are no liars beep beep beep boop no it's
really important to destroy people's
lives and businesses and livelihoods
and families
over this thing oh whoops never mind
just gonna take that in i'm gonna say
good i'm glad we've moved past the
vaccine thing every single person who
lost their job who was dismissed from
the military oh my gosh there are people
who had to leave the military because of
this
every single person should should get
their job back
practically speaking i don't even know
how that's possible i don't know how you
put the pieces back together again
after two and a half years
but it is
total vindication total vindication for
those of us
who were always skeptical of dr fauci
who never believed the hysteria who were
always skeptical of the claims of the
technocrats it's total vindication 100
percent i think you should have gotten
it when dr fauci lied about the masks
and explained that he lied i actually
admitted that he lied about the masks i
think you should have probably
understood it when dr fauci called
himself the representative of science
you definitely should have gotten it
yesterday when trump when dr fauci
called himself a symbol of truth
of the truth
i think we get it now i think
i think we get it now
speaking of dubious science
boston children's hospital
is just
putting its foot right on the
accelerator of our one-way trip to
gamora
they are now offering
gender-affirming hysterectomies for
young girls
the slippery slope has gone we're in
warp speed on the slippery slope it went
from
we had a society where we understood
that men and women are different
to a society where men and women
were kind of seen as interchangeable you
know feminism came around a woman needs
a man like fish needs a bicycle then to
a society especially you see this in the
gay rights movement where men and
women's roles including in
romantic partnerships are totally
blurred and a man can be a woman and a
woman can be a man and then this was
taken to its fullest extreme through
transgenderism where they said no a
woman literally can be a man and a man
literally can be a woman and then then
we said actually if that's true then it
can't just be true for adults it's got
to be true for kids because you know
you're born this way and you've you
you've got the soul of a woman in the
body of a man from the moment that
you're conceived even though you're not
really a person when you're conceived
you're only a person when the feminists
want to admit that a baby's become a
baby but that's actually a side point i
digress we have to trans the children
it's very important we're going to bring
transgenderism down to even elementary
school and we're going to at least at
the very least put them on totally
reversible
uh totally reversible puberty blockers
and those totally reversible cross-sex
hormones even though all of these drugs
that then get you on the hook to big
pharma for life at a huge expense huge
profits for big pharma even though they
cause all sorts of problems and you're
beginning to see this osteoporosis
sometimes permanent sterility in kids
that's no big deal don't worry it's
totally reversible oh yeah and now also
we're going to surgically remove the
wombs of children
to accommodate this absurd
fad this cult called transgenderism so
says
boston
children's
hospital
here's the advertisement gender bombing
hysterectomy is very similar to most
hysterectomies that occur
hysterectomy itself is the removal of
the uterus the cervix which is the
opening of the uterus and the fallopian
tubes which are attached to the sides of
the uterus some gender-affirming
hysterectomies will also include the
removal of the ovaries but that's
technically a separate procedure called
a bilateral oophorectomy and not every
gender firming hysterectomy includes
that and people who are getting gender
forming hysterectomies do not have to
have their ovaries removed
smiley smiley yeah so um what we're
gonna do
is not everyone has to have their
ovaries removed okay you know you've
noticed this how liberal usually white
millennial women they end every question
or every sentence rather as though it
were a question and it always kind of
ends up and it's on a lilt and it's
really nice it sounds nice but you can
tell there's a tension there because
what they're talking about is totally
insane and really really scary and
vaguely threatening so we're gonna
remove your fallopian tubes and maybe
take out your ovaries
but at the very least little kids we're
gonna remove your womb
you expect when you see this kind of
evil in the country you expect it to
come with a pitchfork and horns
and maybe a kind of scary demonic voice
or listen kids we're gonna cut your womb
out ah but but it's not how it happens
actually
it's even more insidious than that it
happens in the name of compassion and
being really nice you know and being
really polite and that's why little
girls we're going to chop your womb out
because you mistakenly think you're a
boy and we're going to affirm you in
that delusion and then you're going to
regret it later on and we're going to
have destroyed your body in your life
obviously this should be shut down
anyone who is donating any money to this
hospital should stop on look i'm sure
the hospital does great work otherwise
they need to
put massive pressure
cultural and social pressure to shut
down this clinic which is really
performing true evil on little kids and
then we need political pressure to shut
this down from the level of the city and
the state needs to be banned the people
who who perform these kinds of surgeries
should be in prison
certainly
maybe
maybe you have a kind of amnesty right
now and you say okay people who were
wrongly doing this you didn't understand
it it was legal okay so we're not going
to throw you in the gulags yet but
now we've passed this law if anyone even
so much as thinks about performing the
surgery afterward you're going to prison
we're throwing away the key we're going
to treat you so viciously in prison it
will be as though you danced around the
capital rotunda in a horn head on
january 6th that's how harsh we're going
to be to you for chopping out the wombs
of little girls you freaking psychos
it's everywhere this ideology is
everywhere in society now it's not just
on the extreme crazy fringes of the
capitol hill autonomous zone in some
bizarre left-wing city with a bunch of
anarchists and misfits and miscreants
running the show this is happening in
our elite institutions boston children's
hospital is a prestigious institution
it's happening right here in my own town
i love nashville nashville's so great
i've been in nashvillia now for two
years or something love tennessee
and you can even see it creeping in here
i fled liberal california
to be in a normal place
and yet here
you've got
the elite girls school harpeth hall
just announced even the elite school in
tennessee
is going trans
harpeth hall dates back to 1865.
it's an all girls school i don't have
any daughters yet i hope at some point
to have daughters i am i think i might
be too virile i just keep producing men
i am just so filled to the brim with y
chromosomes and and just brute
masculinity that i keep producing boys
but at some point i may have a girl and
i hope i do so that i can grant people
favors on her wedding day if i have a
girl someday if i am so blessed i cannot
send her to harpett hall i can't do it
because harpeth hall has just gone trans
because harpist hall which was the girls
school in tennessee
is no longer a girls school even though
they're pretending to be a girls school
orbithal produced reese witherspoon amy
grant mini pearl lots of famous alumnae
not alumni alumni would would imply just
boys or boys and girls but it's alumnae
because it's just girls but now they
don't produce alumnae they produce
alumni
the website of the school says people
need to live honorably and think
critically
until transgenderism i guess and then
you throw a critical thought out the
window the school's board of trustees
diversity equity and inclusion committee
has just created this new policy at the
request of the school's administration
the policy claims that trustees quote
have heard from experts on the topic
shared educational articles and
consulted with other girls schools so
here's how i know i couldn't send my
daughter to harpett hall someday in
nashville because
they they don't know anything about
anything they say they've consulted
experts
but you don't need an expert to know
boys and girls are different you don't
need to be an expert to know that boys
can't become little girls and girls
can't become little boys so if the
school at the very highest levels is so
confused on this that they don't know
the difference between boys and girls
then i can't trust them to teach my
daughter anything because they don't
know anything they are demonstrating
such a degree of ignorance and idiocy
maybe willful ignorance i suspect it is
that i couldn't i couldn't trust them to
teach my kids the abcs
the policy quote any
student who identifies as a girl may
apply to our school so they give in to
the fad
and it's not going to turn out well i
mentioned this this quote yesterday on
the show i don't know if it's from
fulton sheen or dean inge i don't know
something i think the catholics and the
protestants fight over who gets to claim
this quote it's a brilliant quote i love
it whoever said it
whoever marries himself to the spirit of
the age will find himself a widower in
the next
if you marry yourself to the spirit of
the age you will become a widow in the
next because the spirit of the age is
always changing and that's why you've
got to ground yourself in eternal truths
not in passing fads and transgenderism
is a passing fad that's not even a
prediction that's just an historical
fact transgenderism has cropped up at
various times throughout history in
different forms and different kinds of
transgender expressions i guess you
could say but it's come up as the
gnostic dualist heresy it's come up in a
way as albigensianism catherism
it's come up
in in various forms and now it's coming
up in this particular transgender way
it's already beginning to pass away in
some cases there's a wonderfully
encouraging
uh report that's come out right now
there is an infamous
gender clinic in great britain i've
covered it on this show it's called the
tavistock gender clinic in london they
offer quote gender affirming care and
puberty blockers to thousands of
children
1 000 families are now filing a medical
negligence lawsuit against the clinic
they're they're targeting the gender
identity development service at
tavistock and portman nhs trust which
they claim rightly uh recklessly doled
out puberty blockers with harmful side
effects of course these quote this is
from the the people who are bringing
this
the children have suffered life-changing
and in some cases irreversible effects
of the treatment they received we
anticipate at least 1 000 clients will
join this action
tip of the iceberg
this is just one clinic in just one part
of the united kingdom not even here in
the united states yet
we also predicted this on the show years
ago you were going to see sooner rather
than later lawsuits being brought by
people who as children were subjected to
these medical experiments who later on
realize that they're extremely harmful
and they're going to sue their parents
and they're going to sue the doctors and
they're going to sue the government in
some cases if the government is
providing health care good we need more
of that we need these these institutions
to be absolutely bankrupted ideally you
would see the people who perform these
kinds of mutilations and experiments
have their livelihoods destroyed thrown
in prison if possible but at the very
least
totally ostracized
from public life at the very least until
they repent and recant and beg
beg
forgiveness of what they've done to
these poor little kids speaking of
dubious science
it's quite a story
quite a story just came out
this was trending on
social media yesterday the story comes
from cnbc the earth spun faster than
usual on june 29th and triggered climate
anxiety
here's how to cope did you suffer any
climate anxiety
did you have i didn't know the earth
spun faster i mean all of my colleagues
are out of the office either just not
showing up or calling in sick so it it
has felt faster to me
because that sometimes when we work a
lot or you have a newborn kid at home
that makes the time feel like it's going
a little faster because we have a lot to
do i don't generally feel the actual
physical earth spinning faster it
doesn't it doesn't bother me too much
i've got other things in my life
to worry about than that
but some people i guess don't
but they worry about is climate anxiety
here's how you can cope by the way
try a news detox
designate a timer multiple times
throughout the day when you don't
consume any news that's a good idea at
least when we're talking about cnbc at
least when we're talking about the
washington post just lately i don't
think you need to take a news detox from
the michael knowles show because we're
not uh
selling you a bunch of ridiculous lies
to freak you out and and just
force you into supporting our
environmentalist program by
fear-mongering and telling you the world
is going to end in nine years if you
don't if you don't raise taxes on
certain industries and drive a tesla
okay we're not gonna we're not gonna lie
to you and manipulate you that way so i
don't think you need to detox from us
you definitely need to detox from these
extremely toxic news sources then
this one's my favorite find a community
talk to others about what you're feeling
and consider climate cafes
these are groups that meet up to discuss
the state of the world
or you could just like go to church like
you're supposed to because that's really
what this is about right find a
community that you can get get together
with
and
and
talk about your energy and feelings to
try to save the world you're saying to
pray you really want to pray that's the
word you want to use you just you don't
know how to say it she's saying come
into a community where you pray that you
won't be destroyed and the world will be
saved and you're describing a church but
in this bizarre lib way you're taking
your natural longing for god because man
is a fundamentally religious being but
you're denying god and you're denying
true religion and so that you're
channeling it in all these bizarre ways
you'll you'll feel a lot better if you
just go to church okay you will rather
than setting up coffee dates with a
bunch of other liberal neurotics to talk
about how the world's going to end in
five minutes just
just go to church
okay
take it take a detox from these absolute
looney tunes and take a detox from all
the fear-mongering and the lies and and
the the constant dishonesty and
deception
and just
see things the way they are all right
it's so you'll feel a lot better when
you tune out that washington post and
you tune out that cnbc and you recognize
that there are more important things in
the world than the ones the libs want
you all to worry about
the corporate media not only control
what they want you to know their agenda
means that the news is presented in a
biased way you know it i know we all
know it thankfully there's a way to get
the most important news of the day
without that narrative that is by
listening to one of the top news
podcasts morning wire morning wire has
new episodes available every morning
seven days a week they cover stories
other media outlets won't touch
you'll find morning wire on apple
podcast spotify dailywear plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts
now finally we have reached my
favorite time of the week
when i get to hear from you
in the voicemail bag our mailbag is
sponsored by puretalk go to puretalk.com
select a plan and enter promo code
knowles podcast to get your first month
free
you'll get a free month you'll save two
thirds on your cell phone service you'll
get the best service out there you'll
get great phones and most importantly
you will keep the voicemail bag on the
air
take it away
hey michael huge fan of the show also a
big fan of the voicemail bag shout out
to puretalk for making this happen my
question to you today is about south
park so i've noticed that you've made
multiple references to south park not
only does it appear in your book
speechless but also you've brought up
episodes on the show before like the
transgender episode where he competes in
sports and how ridiculous that is and
how it's barely even satire and then
just a week or two ago you talked about
how south park picked up on the fact
that donald trump delivered a lot of his
speeches in the cadence of a comedian
and how they made a parody of that so i
have two questions first do you watch
south park and second do you think it's
okay to watch south park because i think
it's hilarious i think it's extremely
witty and that it's a perfect use of
satire to show us how ridiculous
our society is but also it's extremely
vulgar
it mocks religion and mocks christianity
and it has a lot of inappropriate themes
sexual innuendos things like that so is
it okay to engage with south park or
similar media and use it as
entertainment even if it doesn't align
with our values thanks
great question
yes i think so but as with anything
you've got to be a little careful i
think trey parker and matt stone who
made south park i think they're geniuses
i think south park generally speaking is
very well done i don't really watch it
anymore i've been watching it since
almost the first episodes even when i
was a little kid
i i just don't watch a ton of tv anymore
at most i'll watch one episode
of
one show every couple of days now so i
just i but i love i still really love
south park they don't get everything
right and they get some things pretty
wrong and you mention on religion they
get some things really really wrong i
remember their episode about mel gibson
and the passion of the christ movie
which was in part very very funny that
they really missed it they really missed
the boat because as i recall the
conclusion of that episode was we
shouldn't think about how jesus died we
should just think about what he taught
which is just a really ignorant shallow
understanding of christianity the point
actually is that he died and suffered in
the passion and on the cross and then
rises again from the dead in the
resurrection and redeems man from sin
conquer sin on the cross and then comes
back up and heroes hell and opens up the
gates of heaven and so if you if you
miss that it just exposes a really
shallow understanding of christianity
but i think it's worth pointing out trey
parker and matt stone are not atheists
well what they've said though they mock
all sorts of religions they mock
mormonism famously
they they say that of all the crazy wild
religious claims out there
i think it was trey parker made this
point he said the craziest one i've ever
heard is that this whole world that
we're living in everything all of
creation all our loves and fears and
hopes and dreams it's all just cuz just
cause whatever you know uh
he says the craziest religion is atheism
and so i
though he mocks religion and maybe they
haven't exhibited the highest level
understanding of religion
i don't think they're exactly hostile to
religion
necessarily um and and their political
satire is very often
really really great and especially in
those early seasons really really funny
stuff uh so yeah as with anything you
know do i think it's okay to have a
drink i do
you should probably not have 15 drinks
and then you know go get in your car and
go on a rampage downtown but
enjoyed responsibly i think south park
is is really really funny next question
hi michael i'm struggling to understand
god and now he decides to answer prayers
i consider the countless times i have
set a prayer for something trivial like
finding my car keys and i believe to
have god help me in those situations i
then relate this to a real desperate
problem such as a mother losing her
children to kidnapping and she is trying
desperately to find them so often those
children are never found even though the
loving parents may have prayed so
fervently and lived righteously in the
gospel
this contrast between the two makes me
confused about prayer completely why
would god help me discover the major i
should take in school the girls i should
date the friends i should find but then
so often won't help mothers and fathers
find their lost children or won't help a
child escape for instance from a
tyrannical government or abusive family
i believe prayer is essential in life to
align ourselves to god god's will but
these contrasting situations has been
completely perplexed but i think you can
help me understand thanks so much
really good question you're asking about
two distinct
concepts and i think your confusion is
coming is because you're you're eliding
the two a little bit
when we pray
jesus tells us how to pray in the
gospels he says when you pray pray like
this
our father who art in heaven hallowed be
thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done on earth as it is in heaven the
prayer goes on
thy will be done is very very important
here then you fast forward to jesus in
the garden of gethsemane where he's
awaiting his passion and crucifixion
and he says
he prays to god the father he says
please
father let this cup pass from my lips
but not now my will be done but thy will
be done
so
christ anticipating experiencing the
worst possible thing
that anyone could possibly experience
that he uniquely can experience that we
actually can't even really experience
because we're not god
and
he says but not my will be done but thy
will be done so when we ask things of
god and we
of course we ask things of god there are
different kinds of prayer there's prayer
where you're sort of just contemplating
and
adoring god and worshiping god there's
prayer where you are petitioning god and
you're asking god for certain things
you know when i was in that delivery
room with sweet little elise a couple
weeks ago you know i was praying please
god let this all go okay let this all be
safe and good and everything and so i'm
making
an ask
now when we are making an ask of god we
are we are
relying on god's omnipotence and we're
making
an ask of god's omnipotence
we do not have the power
and in the gospel when christ says ask
and you shall receive that does not mean
that we have the power to boss god
around if we could boss god around god
would not be god that would be
incoherent
frequently when we ask things of god we
get them
in a way that can be quite
surprising
the first the first few times it happens
in a way that can seem miraculous and
sometimes is miraculous but you don't
always get what you want and in those
cases what we are called upon to do
is trust not merely in god's omnipotence
but in god's omniscience in god's
all-knowing
in god's knowing that
listen kid i know you're upset now i
know this can be really hard but where
were you when i laid the foundations of
the world where were you when i set the
order to the universe you really think
you're going to do a better job than i
am at this thing i don't think so
the a great way to think about this and
this has happened in my own life is
where you you're up for a job and you
really want to get this job and this is
your dream job and you think it'll make
a great life and then you don't get it
and you're really disappointed you pray
and you say why didn't i get that dream
job and then two seconds later you end
up in some other job that's way way
better and gives you a way way way
better life and you couldn't have known
that god knew that but you couldn't have
known that
and i i don't mean to suggest by the way
that every time something you ask for
that is material and you don't get it
that you're going to get something
greater that is in the material world
you might not
you might you might not get the dream
job and then you might get cancer and
then you might suffer for six years and
then you might die and still
you might you you might and i think
will ultimately be
edified and sanctified by that or
certainly
certainly you could be certainly that
could be
and will be the best possible world
some people ask why do we have free will
if we didn't have free will then there
wouldn't have been a fall in the garden
and then everything would be perfect and
darn it adam and eve why'd you have to
do that
how can this be the greatest of all
possible worlds how can god be all good
if we live in this fallen world and the
conclusion seems to me has to be that
the the fallen world
with the incarnation and with the
atonement is is actually better than
just adam and eve gallivanting around
the garden of eden in perpetuity this is
what christians exclaim on easter when
they say oh happy fault that one for us
so great so glorious a redeemer next
question hello mr knowles
i am a christian conservative kansan and
i voted no on the value them both
amendment
i did not vote no because i am a squish
but precisely because i am not one
the vtb amendment's legislative wording
would have impeded abortion from being
fully banned in the future
dobbs left it possible to regulate
abortion in the states
this pro-life bill would cement
regulation into our law and therefore
not allow it to be banned
and so i voted no
to be clear i'm specifically an
abolitionist
our voting beliefs are different from
the pro-life movement since
abolitionists only vote on legislature
that bans abortion from conception
is immediate and uncompromising
and criminalizes all parties involved
allowing exceptions for abortion is
unbiblical
if we truly want abortion to be
abolished in our country
we need to treat this crime as one by
giving it criminal consequences for both
the doctor and the parents no matter the
circumstances the child was conceived in
i'm curious as to what your take is on
my decision to vote no and on the
abolitionist movement as a whole
really really good question
uh the short answer is i disagree with
your stance tactically but not not in
principle
so you're you're referencing this uh
kansas referendum this amendment that
came up for a referendum that failed and
i i should point out i i just read some
headlines about it on the show and
people wrote in and they said michael
you misrepresented what the amendment
was and i have no doubt that i did i was
basically just reading some amendments
about
some headlines rather about the
amendment and i think part of the reason
it failed and part of part of the
uh controversy around it is because
there was some confusion especially in
the press probably intentional about
what that amendment would do
so let's take take your understanding of
the amendment that actually this could
really hurt us in the long term because
it would make it impossible to get
totally perfect pro-life legislation and
therefore you voted no i totally respect
that
stance
and i'll plead ignorance on the minutia
of the amendment to begin with so i'll
zoom it out from the that specific
kansas amendment to the issue more
broadly
i am perfectly willing
to take a 90 win
and then try to get the next 10
later on
i think that's fine i
generally fear letting the perfect get
in the way of the good
i'm perfectly willing to make
incremental change
you might object and say no the
incremental change is actually going to
reduce the likelihood
that we get
the the perfect
outcome that i want
i don't think that's true i think that
the way politics works is through
momentum
so i think incremental change actually
will help us to achieve a kind of
perfect goal in this case
banning abortion period
but
reasonable people can disagree on that
the disagreement that we're having is
merely tactical though i don't think
it's a disagreement on the principle
next question
hey michael
my question is in regards to childhood
sports i've got one son who is very
athletic and has shown
interest in pretty much all sports but
has definitely expressed interest in
playing football
one day um and given how dangerous it is
i'm just curious what your thoughts are
on football and if you plan to let your
sons play if they want to or if you plan
on trying to steer them more towards
you know soccer or tennis or baseball
basketball what have you thanks michael
just knowing the knolls jeans uh
probably
this is an unfounded fear that i would
have that they will be football stars um
but maybe it's possible listen my eldest
son he's got a really good arm and my
newborn son he came out looking like a
real bruiser so maybe they'll be they'll
be real you know tough kids i mean my
gosh the second kid came he was over
nine pounds you know he's a big big guy
so maybe maybe they'll be big stores i
would i would not guide them to soccer
which i think is uh an abomination i
would probably guide them toward
baseball the real american pastime a
football is is a little bit dangerous i
agree with that and so i would i would
be hesitant i would have i would take a
moment and probably discourage them from
that i also think baseball's a better
sport
but
i would at least be open to it
although i would i would guide them in
the direction of baseball i want to get
to at least one or two regular mailbag
questions before we go from julia
michael love the show i believe every
child needs both a mother and a father
which is why i don't support gay
adoption sounds like you agree with this
idea this led me to wonder if you also
believe single people should be barred
from adopting thoughts thanks yes
absolutely single people should be
barred from adopting if you believe that
men and women both have something to
offer humanity and children then i don't
understand how you can support
homosexual adoption or single adoption i
know that some people really want to
have kids homosexuals want to have kids
single people want to have kids it's not
about you it's about the kid the only
people who can be said to have rights in
that kind of situation we're talking
about the upbringing of kids
are the kids
so no there are 36 couples estimated for
every uh one newborn baby put up for
adoption in the united states 36 couples
who want to adopt so we should
prioritize
people who are married who are actually
married man and woman in a real marriage
to adopt those children no question last
question from kyle
michael when will senator cruz announce
you as his running mate thanks kyle i
don't there are few few issues with that
one uh senator i'm not being coy here or
anything i don't know if senator cruz is
going to run for president in 2024 and
then there's this minor issue which is
that i'm constitutionally ineligible at
the moment because i will not be 35 on
the day of the election or the
inauguration so we're just gonna have to
wait
gonna have to wait at least one more
cycle i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you next time
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022